so the truth Michael is that you're
targeting a population that's vulnerable
for political clout and you just got
caught in 4k do better are you that dumb
are you that stupid you're just
lazy lazy lazy lazy
[Music]
hey everybody Michael Knowles here would
you believe it some people don't love me
me whom everybody loves so there are
some people apparently who don't love me
and they make mean tick tocks about me
and look I got thick skin man I'm a
tough guy so I'm gonna look at them head
on and see if any of this criticism is
valid or if it's all just a bunch of
bunk take it away there's no competition
Michael Knowles wins stickiest fingers
contest you know that uh
any event if Michael knows has a
handheld mic there's an intern that has
to come in and wipe that mic down
because it's just so grimy and gross
from his oily little sticky fingers
is that an Italian thing what have I
ever done to make you treat me so
disrespectfully as they say we're like
grease balls you know that's
anti-italian discrimination and it's
true I I do I do make some oil that's
how my skin looks so nice and young
that's how my hair stays so slick and
shiny yeah we're a little oily I produce
beautiful delicious extra virgin first
cold pressed olive oil right out of the
pores of my skin that's who I am that's
who we are as a people and I'm not going
to apologize to whatever kind of lady
that is next one
quite the same as men putting on dresses
and stilettos and stripping half naked
and jiggling for little kids at a CD bar
okay those are different things yeah we
should take our kids to places that is
appropriate for them to be General so
it's appropriate for them to be
titillated at Hooters they're accusing
me of something that I didn't say I'm
not saying it's good to take your
five-year-old to Hooters or anything
like that but the question at hand was
this this totally contrived scenario
that the libs and the pro drag people
will will present which is hold on why
is it bad for a drag queen to go read to
your five-year-old in the elementary
school but then meanwhile some people
take their children to have chicken
fingers at Hooters where do you want to
go
it would still be worse to expose the
kid to the drag thing not all weird sex
stuff is equal human sexuality has a
purpose and Men Are Made for women and
women are made for men and so even
things that are naughty and immoral and
not conducive to Virtue and flourishing
are not age-appropriate or whatever if
they're broadly recognizing that men are
for women and women are for men that is
still more in accord with natural law
than some weirdo drag queen pretending
to be a different sex yeah just like gay
is bad and straight is good that's
that's all he's saying no and and the
the kind of I guess yeah they're boys to
Hooters is because they want to impart
some sort of like heterosexual wink and
non-thing onto them like let's have this
shared experience Hooters is like
explicitly I even understood this as a
kid when I drove past there when I was
like you know eight I was like oh like
put a pause there I love this this is
what liberals do all the time she says
look I I understood what Hooters is all
about when I was a kid and I drove past
wait a second hold on did you go there
or you no I just drove past there and
then but I then that's how I learned
what it was about because I imagined
what it was like and they do this with
things like Catholicism especially
people say oh yeah there was a Catholic
Church in my town so trust me I I know
what I'm talking about even though I
have no firsthand experience and have
never seriously explored anything
pertaining to uh the faith or in this
case to a chicken restaurant with
scintillating outfits on the waitresses
um drag shows are not sexual like I
don't understand by far yeah there are
sexual drag shows I'm sure for the most
part what I've seen is it's theatrical
it's fun it's way theatrical that's like
the key word it's about dressing
lipstick it's about dressing up in an
overtly sexual caricature sort of way
wearing big stiletto heels and all sorts
of big outfits that that you probably
wouldn't wear to a wedding or a funeral
or church on Sunday I think we can admit
that right because the outfits are meant
to be sexual either in a comedic way or
in a titillating way or often both
singing to Jolene by Dolly Parton is not
sexual it's not as sexual as uh the name
of this fast food chain which has shitty
food is about yeah okay first of all
look I like they're setting me up like
I'm the big defender of Hooters I've
been to a Hooters like three times in my
life usually at Bachelor parties and
that sort of thing all I'll tell you
about Hooters they make a great chicken
wing I will give you two reasons the
boobs and the hot wings they make great
chicken so I will not allow them to
besmirch the chicken at Hooters but
furthermore that last Point she tries to
make There She Goes you know a drag
queen dressed up like Dolly Parton you
know there's there's nothing sexual
about Dolly Parton what are you talking
about Dolly Parton for her entire I know
she's a little a woman of a certain age
now but for her entire career she's worn
skimpy or at the very least uh I don't
know titillating kind of outfits you
know it's a good looking lady and that's
what she's done so of course yeah if uh
and if a big hulking dude dresses up in
little skirts and boots and high heels
yeah that has a sexual aspect
Minneapolis is now a Muslim City it's a
little strange to think given
Minnesota's traditional demographic
makeup as ethnically whiter than the
driven snow and religiously
again classical Western brainwashing
don't you see Minnesota's whitest snow
genius we're not talking about race
we're talking about religion and Islam
is a religion for everyone your welcome
as well to accept Islam put a pause
there we're talking about the Muslims in
Minnesota pal they're you know not
coming from Iberia
[Music]
maybe he's just unaware of how
immigration has worked in the United
States they tend to be a little more
from these Somalian region of Islam than
from I don't know the Muslims of Finland
if there are any so I think the I think
my observation still holds Islam came
for the world you don't have to be brown
to be a Muslim you don't have to be but
you know it helps you sure have got
yourself a Muslim I think he's kind of
nitpicking because he doesn't want to
get to the underlying point I'm making
about immigration and culture so often
the case what was my favorite attack on
me
and gross from his oily little sticky
fingers drag shows are not sexual
Sticky Fingers that was my favorite one
because they're not sticky but they're
oily and we Children of the mezzojorno
we we make a little oil
that's true see you next time that was
worse than an Italian guy describing
someone's sexuality anyway My Brother
Louie he said he's a little off to the
side you know the full fee up to the
knuckle he's a he's a backwards mechanic
he likes to play in the dirt you mean
gay
he's creative
[Music]